hello and welcome to Emma Barnett meets
and this week I'm meeting the space
experts and physicist Professor Brian
Cox and I'm really looking forward to
asking him about how he gets his head
around the vastness of space and to
explain it to all of us or try to anyway
how he also goes about his daily life
when he knows how insignificant we
really are and what he makes of NASA's
new telescope and those amazing images
[Music]
welcome to the program thank you so much
for coming to talk to me and to all of
our viewers and I actually wanted to
start with the new NASA telescope we'll
come to your particular project in a
moment but it's named after the man who
ran the agency in the 60s and oversaw
the first man Mission To The Moon James
Webb what do you make of of what we're
seeing so far because it's pretty
incredible yeah it's a remarkable
instrument and you think of the
predecessor which is the Hubble Space
Telescope
um I think it's almost impossible to
imagine a world without that
um even if you you don't know the images
that we're familiar with of the universe
many of them the spectacular you know
galaxies in Star forming Regions they're
from Hubble but the web is a significant
step forward and and technically one of
the most important things is it can see
what we call longer wavelength light or
the infrared light and that's important
because if you think about we want to
see the first galaxies forming so we
want to understand how the first stars
and galaxies formed in the universe and
so what you do is you look far out into
the universe and because light travels
quite slowly across Cosmic distances
let's say you have a Galaxy that's um
the most distant one you can see with
the naked eye is about two million light
years away so that means that the light
has been traveling for two million years
to reach us and it's a remarkable thing
actually to think when you look it's
called the Andromeda galaxy and if you
know where you're looking you can just
catch you out of the corner of your eye
if you think about it you're seeing that
as it was two million years ago yes it
takes a like two million years to travel
I don't like being late to information
so that makes me feel very out of date
it's remarkable I mean it began its
Journey before we had evolved on Earth
so in the time it took and that's the
nearest neighboring Galaxy you know the
web looks so far out that it's capturing
light that's been traveling for over 13
billion years but the universe has been
expanding and so the light has been
stretching and so for the most distant
galaxies we're looking back back in time
almost to the Big Bang then that the
Hubble was not sensitive to that light
so that the web can see the formation of
the first galaxies it's essentially
looking all the way back to very close
to the beginning of time and that's very
important because we're not entirely
sure exactly how this first galaxies
formed the idea of what you just talked
about in terms of how much time this has
taken and what it's covering do you
think we will ever be able to see the
Big Bang
well um we we almost can it's not the
web telescope there's something called
The Cosmic microwave background
radiation which is light that was
emitted in the universe and it's a very
precise number it's 380 000 years after
the big bang which is not very long at
all right the universe is 13.8 billion
years old so we can see that it's it's
microwaves because it's been stretched
so much by the expansion of the universe
going back that the problem with light
is that in those earliest times the
universe was so hot and so dense that
light couldn't travel through it so it
was opaque so you can't use light to go
back earlier than that but what we can
potentially do not yet we're not good
enough yet but the technology we use to
now to detect colliding black holes
which is another remarkable thing but
I'll leave that one aside for now but we
have the technology to do that and that
technology possibly could allow us to
probe right back to to this thing the
big bang and again whether or not that's
the origin of time we can talk about as
well Brian you've dedicated your life to
explaining the Scale of the Universe to
people you have a new world tour and
show called Horizons what's the goal
I'll be are you trying to teach people
new things and and understand the world
they're living in better or what are you
aiming for well actually all those
things so um it works I hope on
different levels so I talk about
cosmology to be spoken about you know
that what we call the large-scale
structure of the universe so the
galaxies and how they formed How the
Universe has evolved since the big bank
but also I've got very interested in my
academic work in black holes and black
holes and they're really evocative
things I think everyone's heard of these
strange things these totally collapsed
stars from which nothing apparently can
escape but in the past few years past
few decades really and beginning work
that Stephen Hawking really began back
in the 1970 70s and many others and
we've begun to suspect there's a lot
more to them and they've started forcing
us to reassess our understanding of what
space and time are and that's a really
weird sentence you might think well
space is the the arena in which we live
in time just ticks but it really isn't
it looks like from studying these things
there are building blocks of space and
building blocks of time and what I say
in the show is that's a mind-blowing
idea and I talk about that but the key
point is there's a great quote from
Einstein a beautiful story
that Einstein told about when he was a
little boy he was six or seven years old
and his dad gave him a compass and so he
looked at the compass and and he saw
well there's this thing this needle and
it always points North points in this
direction so there's something invisible
that I can't see that underlies our
reality that's making this needle point
North and he said later in life it was
my first encounter with it with an idea
which is if you look at nature carefully
and really pay attention and you're
lucky you can catch a glimpse of
something deeply hidden which is a
beautiful phrase something deeply hidden
which is the Deep structure of reality
it's what our reality is and so black
holes I they're kind of a metaphor in a
way I talk about them as Rosetta Stones
in the sky they're the things that by
studying them and you and you say why
why would we study these things well in
studying these things we're beginning to
get a deep a deep picture of what our
reality actually is and that's a
remarkable idea but it's a beautiful
idea that runs through all of science
how do you define a black hole well it's
um in Einstein's theory which again is a
remarkable thing it's published in 1915
over 100 years old but it's just a
region of space
from which even light can't escape and
by understanding what they are and
knowing more about them what what do we
then learn well so Stephen Hawking back
in the 70s published a paper
um the initial one was called black hole
explosions which is a great title for a
paper and he calculated he found out
that black holes in his in his language
he said black holes Ain't So black like
they glow in the sky like coals in the
sky and they radiate and so over time
they lose energy and mass and ultimately
disappear of a huge time scales and
that's so important and I I show this
picture in the show that if you go into
Westminster Abbey and look on the floor
of Westminster Abbey on Stephen's
memorial stone then you find his
equation for the temperature of a black
hole literally chiseled in stone on the
floor of an Abbey so you might say why
why is it so important this was the key
this was this Rosetta Stone idea in
trying to understand what happens what
happens what happens to the stuff that
fell in it was it was when you thought
these things existed forever which is
pre-hawking right
um then you think well it's okay it gets
locked up inside it can never get out we
don't care but the thing evaporates away
one day it will be gone
so then suddenly you have to be faced
with this question what happened to
everything then
um if I throw a book into a black hole
is it somehow possible in the far future
if you collect all this so-called
Hawking radiation that comes off is it
possible to reconstruct the information
in the book and that that's been a
question simple question that's driven
this is a tremendous amount of research
for 50 years and it was pretty much
solved in 2019 actually in 2020. pretty
much I mean there's still a huge number
of questions but roughly well the
statement is everything comes out again
all the information comes out so so
everything that fell in in principle in
the far future You Could reconstruct the
information of everything that fell in
this is an astonishing idea because
actually the last thing I'll say is that
before that before the Hawking papers
and before this modern understanding
inside a black hole just according to
Einstein since the end of time which is
an astonishing thing to say because we
can see them we have a photograph of one
of these things in the center of a
galaxy too actually now and you're
looking when you look at that photograph
you're looking at the end of time in
space so then you think well if things
go to the End of Time how does
everything get out again and that's the
content of the this tremendous work in
theoretical physics and this work
studying black holes which is probably
it's one of those things that a certain
kind of person says is useless right you
said why who cares right it turns out
that the techniques that have been
developed and the understanding that's
being gained from looking at these
things has got a very strong Crossover
with building quantum computers right
which is a quantum computers are in
Laboratories now they have a tremendous
potential to revolutionize our
civilization incredibly powerful
Computing devices well yes and also
that's sometimes the defense given isn't
it about you know what's going into man
going back to the moon or woman going
back to the moon the other things are
discovered in the pursuit of those
missions yeah I mean it's it's always a
cliche but it's true a friend of mine
um an astronomer always says when people
criticize these spacecraft and they say
you know the way let's say the James
Webb Space Telescope is what six billion
dollars or so
um but it's appropriate finds out that
nobody put six billion dollars in a
suitcase and launched it on the Rock kit
right the six billion dollars didn't go
into space it was spent on Earth
and what what is often the case so
putting aside the the glory and wonder
of the discoveries that are made that it
basically you're you're paying people to
do high-tech jobs and do research and
build machines that operate at the the
the edge of the possible and history
tells us that that tends to be extremely
useful you're inventing things and
trying to do things that are difficult
and that that expertise never stays in
one place it then spreads out across our
civilization in ways that you can't
really predict or even quantify indeed
and and you did sound very excited
earlier I mean you sound excited the
whole time about all of this which is
which is infectious even if you know
people are trying to keep up including
myself but when you talked about the the
golden possibility of there being uh you
know life out there and that question of
are we alone where are you with that
what do you say to to people right now
with the latest information
well so this again it's I think there's
a in cosmology I say this in the show as
well it's one of the most challenging
subjects because at one level it makes
us feel very very small and
insignificant and it's true you know
physically I mean the Earth is one
planet around one star amongst 400
billion stars in one Galaxy amongst two
trillion galaxies in the part of the
universe we can see right so we're
definitely small right so you can't
argue that yes you clarified but but
you're right if you ask the question
about life
um the answer is we don't know we've
found nothing nothing alive beyond the
Earth but admittedly we haven't been
very far or looked tremendously hard
although we are looking hard now on Mars
because we suspect there might have been
microbes on Mars because there was once
water on Mars and it was geologically
active and all the things that we think
led to the origin of life on Earth were
present on Mars around the same time
about three and a half to four billion
years ago so we wouldn't be surprised if
we find that microbes existed probably
subsurface on Mars and or maybe on some
of the moons of Jupiter or Saturn where
there's water today however
nobody expects anything more complicated
than the microbe
and it's interesting if so if you look
at the history of life on Earth you have
microbes around 3.8 billion years ago
pretty much not long after the Earth
formed in geological time
um but if you look for evidence of
complex life on Earth
then really there isn't any in the
fossil record until about 600 million
years ago or so so on this planet uh for
most of the history of the planets there
was slime basically single-celled things
doing interesting stuff photosynthesis
and things but nothing more complicated
than a single cell and it's only in the
last half a billion years or so that you
get this explosion of life on Earth and
and only as I said it's only in the last
uh less than a million years that we've
had Homo sapiens on Earth and in the
last few tens of thousands of years
we've had a civilization so here it took
pretty much four billion years to go
from cell to civilization and that's the
third of the age of the universe and so
that leaves many biologists that I speak
to to suggest that whilst microbes might
be common civilizations might be rare
actually I asked a friend of mine a
great physicist Sean Carroll um how many
civilizations do you think there would
be in the Milky Way galaxy a typical
Galaxy how many in a typical Galaxy and
he said none
right none and I think he's I I tend to
say one so somewhere between zero and
one probably but that that's a guess but
what what do you do I think it's a good
guess Brian is that is that what it is
you sound like perhaps you have an
optimism for it and I wonder what's in
underpinning that I would look I would
love there to be and actually because it
worries me and I this is the way that I
end my show actually it worries me that
let's him let's take that position let's
imagine that in in our galaxy 400
billion Suns uh there's just us that
thinks right I mean microbes all over
the place but in terms of things that
think and can feel and in a very real
sense bring meaning to the universe all
these things we've talked about the
beauty of these galaxies they're not
beautiful if there's nothing there to
perceive them right they're just
galaxies so if that's it in this galaxy
then the decisions that we make now
as a civilization
have a galactic implications right if we
destroy ourselves for example
deliberately or through inaction then
it's possible that we eliminate meaning
perhaps forever in a galaxy of 400
billion stars and so that's it I think
that leads you to it's a good working
assumption that we have a tremendous
responsibility in a sense not to do that
so I I would be much more comfortable
with our current predicament if if the
Galaxy was filled with civilizations
then I'd say well okay
um it would be rather stupid of us to
eliminate all this beautiful culture and
Science and Arts and Music that we've
built up but at least there's someone
else that's doing that but I'm not
actually sure there is
how comfortable are you with with space
tourism and and the pursuit of that
knowledge and meaning being left largely
to a very small group of rich men you're
right the um the idea that the the
technology is used if all it was used
for it was to send a few very very rich
people into space on a joyride then
there would be a real criticism there
but that's not all the technology is
used for so it I think
I think it's important to understand
that the space industry is is about it's
about operating initially in near-earth
orbits and we've already industrialized
that you know we all use it every day I
mean we all switch on our Sat Nav in the
car satellite navigation it requires
infrastructure in orbit and a lot of the
stuff we know about climate change
resource use and so on that's coming
from satellites so I think it I think
you have to look at the space industry
as a whole
um really and say well it's not just
about it is the same argument was made
for um InterContinental travel by
aircraft and when the first it's true
when the first aircraft were built it
was extremely expensive in The Preserve
of the rich but of course within a few
decades it had democratized travel and
you know we all take advantage of that
every day so I think that's the right
way to look at space it's not to focus
on particular bits of it that we might
not like for for moral reasons or
whatever it is so it's actually I really
do advocate for the facts of looking at
the whole industry which is tremendously
important now it is I mean I I am
interested though that you did say and
and correct me if I'm wrong that all
political leaders should go to space uh
perhaps for some perspective yeah and I
do you still think that most of them
should come back as well most of them
that's the last part of that quote Yeah
and yeah it was that was um it was it
based on an idea which is a very famous
idea called the overview effect
um which is well known the the
astronauts change their view of the or
always as far as I'm aware anyway
when they come back they have a more
positive view of of the value of this
planet and and are very much more
focused on preserving it as a beautiful
place perhaps a unique place place in a
galaxy as I said so I felt that and I do
feel that that having had the thought
the Good Fortune speaking to many
astronauts that they'll experience
um for if the people who make the
decisions the big decisions about our
future could have that experience I
think would be good Investments it's an
extremely hard argument to make you know
that we could we should actually spend
money allowing you know in our case at
the moment our prime minister right so
in the UK you'd say well we should spend
money sending Boris Johnson into space
and bringing him back safely to Earth
again because it would change his view
now I don't think I'd win that argument
um you know but but I think it's a
serious point there which is that it
does seem to change people for the
better when they see our Earth as it
really is which is a fragile thing
against the Blackness of space so yeah I
think it's a it's an argument that I
would I would try to make I would lose
it
because it's very expensive do you want
to go are you willing to go I would love
to
um because as I said I I I'd love to
share that experience yeah of seeing our
world from space I think it's really
unarguably it appears to be a
life-changing experience and it seems to
change individuals for the better you
won't be scared well I don't know I mean
I remember one of my great Heroes John
Young who flew on the Apollo missions
walked on the moon test flew the first
space shuttle and he said that anyone
who sits on top of however many
thousands of tons of liquid hydrogen
helium liquid hydrogen and oxygen and
isn't a bit worried doesn't understand
the problem
so he's probably right
do you have people come and talk to you
about faith do they talk to you about
how religion and and that side of life
fits into your level of knowledge
because I know you've traveled around
the world talking to people
yeah a lot
um it comes up as a question because
cosmology is the it's a science of
Origins
um and actually with the the study of
black holes I mentioned we're even
beginning now to think about what space
and time are so naturally the I say in
the show actually I say when we're
talking about this it's the moment of
creation if there was so we're asking
was there a moment of creation and
that's the correct language to use I
think or it's evocative language but
it's really what we're talking about did
everything come into being or has it
always been here we actually don't even
know the answer to that question really
um so yeah I get asked it a lot because
um I think cosmology is a challenging
science that challenges us to think
about these things that we we often you
know we associate that with theology or
philosophy
um and I think that's that's a good
thing because uh something I very
strongly believe in is that segmenting
or or making little canisters and
putting different Bits Of Human
Experience or different you know music
and art and Theology and philosophy and
Science and segmenting the model is just
the wrong way to look at it what we're
doing is
um a deep level trying to understand
what it means to be human in this
tremendous potentially infinite universe
and and so I I
those questions get asked and ultimately
I say I'm quite straightforward yes I
don't um I'm not a religious person
myself but um but the correct thing to
say even about the question did the
universe have a beginning in time is we
don't know
we don't know and that's it
Professor Brian Cox thank you so much
for your your time and your Insight
thank you very much and thank you to you
for being with us until next time
goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign